aujourd'hui le conseil north atlantic a
décidé d'activer notre plan de défense
c'est une étape prudente et défensives
pour protéger nos nations pendant cette
crise et cela nous permettra de déployer
les forces nécessaires dont les forces
de réponse de l'otan là où il y en a
besoin
nous avons environ 100 avions de chasse
en alerte dans le ciel pour protéger
notre espace aérien et plus de 120
bateaux en mer du grand nord jusqu'à la
mer méditerranée
j'ai demandé la tenue d'un sommet
virtuel des leaders de l'otan demain
pour convenir de la suite
général trinquant bonjour merci de
répondre à france 24 vous êtes ancien
chef de la mission française militaire
française auprès des nations unies je
rebondis sur ce que disait monsieur
stoltenberg l'otan actif des plans de
défense
pour être clair ça ne veut pas dire que
ça ne concerne pas du tout l'ukraine oui
ça ne concerne pas l'ukraine l'ukraine
ne fait pas partie de l'otan
l'article 5 ne s'applique pas mais donc
ça s'applique en revanche à tous les
autres pays du pourtour je pense aux
pays baltes à la pologne à la roumanie
en particulier il y avait déjà des
mesures préalables qui avait été prise
depuis longtemps ce qu'on après
en particulier dans les pays baltes mais
les américains ont déployé aussi de
nouvelles troupes récemment et là la
force de réaction de la rapide de l'otan
a été activée mise en alerte ce qui
permet de déployer à un court préavis
dans les mêmes pays valcke pologne et
roumanie des troupes de façon à
dissuader toute agression au delà de
l'ukraine parce qu'il y à une menace
alors il y à une menace on ne sait pas
si vous voulez le président le discours
du président poutine clairement c'est
qu'il veut gommer tout ce qui s'est
passé à la fin
à la chute de l'empiré soviétique et
donc il veut en particulier que
l'ukraine n'existe plus mais pourquoi
pas appliquer ça aux pays baltes les
pays baltes que c'est la même chose
n'était pas
étaient des pays russe avant avant la
chute du
mur donc ça pourrait s'appliquer à cela
deuxième point de toute façon le
président poutine donne on le voit bien
par toutes les actions qui sont menées y
compris à distance avec des missiles à
activer tous les moyens russe et
s'adonne à l'otan l'occasion par les
systèmes de renseignement de mieux se
renseigner sur tous ces systèmes pour se
préparer à se défendre contre
l'utilisation éventuelle de ce système
ça pourrait réveiller
des guerres des conflits qui sont gelés
depuis des années on pense à la
transnistrie en moldavie par exemple
pourquoi pas la 36e' quand on regarde
bien une carte la transnistrie entre la
moldavie et l'ukraine
ne touche pas tu n'es pas très loin de
la mer noire donc si les troupes russes
ont jusqu'à la mer noire il peut y avoir
sanction je jeu mais je ne pense pas que
ça il ya un impact direct là dessus
l'impact est beaucoup plus globale si
vous voulez le choc que nous recevons
c'est que nous pensions que la guerre
avait disparu de l'europe elle revient
en europe et il faut se préparer dans
l'avenir à avoir des actions de guerre
en europe pas forcément des déboulés de
charges à les lire mais la guerre
informationnelle la guerre
cyber la guerre avec l' usage spatiale
c'est une réalité aujourd'hui il faut
s'y préparer vous êtes donc étonné par
la décision de résilier poutine ah non
moi je suis pas du tout étonnée je
l'avais dit lors de lorsque j'ai entendu
son discours il ya maintenant je le
temps passe si vite ça fait plus d'une
semaine il ya dix jours j'ai été sous le
choc
c'était un autre monde qui s'ouvrait à
nous c'était un
univers qu'on croyait abandonnées et le
discours de ce matin renfort cette
position on quand il vous parle de thé
nazifié l'ukraine on croit rêver donc je
suis pas surpris du tout il a une
stratégie qu'il a établies depuis
longtemps on envoyait les prémices avec
la mise en place d'un certain nombre de
moyens
et je pense qu'il a utilisé la
négociation pour gagner du temps
simplement nous ne sommes pas fait comme
lui et nous croyons encore que la
négociation pouvait l'emporter le
président macron la fête jusqu'au bout
mais malheureusement
nous devons regarder en face abandonner
notre naïveté et comprendre que nous
avons affaire à quelqu'un qui utilisera
la force et qui n'a aucun état d'âme
pour le faire mais général on s'oriente
vers quel genre de conflit les russes
disent ne pas vouloir viser les civils
et pour l'instant que des bases
militaires
bon alors ils disent ne pas vouloir
viser les civils c'est ce qu'on appelle
les frappes chirurgicales ceci étant il
ya déjà des civils qui sont bord c'est
le premier point deuxièmement c'est
quelque chose qui va
qui va probablement s'amplifier si vous
voulez une guerre de 100 ans de cette
ampleur sans avoir
des accrochages avec des civils ne se
comprend pas et de toute façon les
ukrainiens ne vont pas accepter cette
présence militaire russe et donc il y à
fort à parier qu'il y ait des pertes
civiles importantes
l'armée ukrainienne elle s'est fortement
étoffé depuis 2014 elle disposait de
quelques milliers d'hommes maintenant
250 mille soldats des centaines de
milliers de réservistes mais au fond
elle ne pourra pas faire seul le poids
face à face aux russes oui c'est clair
c'est clair malheureusement et les
ukrainiens se retrouve tout seul dans
leur misère aujourd'hui tout seul sur le
combat militaire pas tout seul parce que
la communauté internationale se
regroupent condamne à exception notoire
de la chine donc il ya une alliance
chine russe la russie qui est très
inquiétante mais je pense que l'aide qui
pourrait être apportée par le par la
communauté internationale ne sera que
sur le long terme et que dans le court
terme malheureusement ils leur foi
affronte et aujourd'hui les combats
l'armée russe tout seul mais de quelles
aides vous vous parlez alors la première
est c'est ces deux d'isoler complètement
la russie aussi bien sur le plan
monétaire
financier économique mais aussi sur le
long terme aider l'ukraine à se
redresser parce que je pense pas que la
russie
occupe et d'ailleurs le président
poutine l'a dit lui-même occupe
l'ukraine mais en revanche l'économie
ukrainienne va être au plus bas et ça va
être extrêmement difficile pour
l'économie ukrainienne
pour l'instant les occidentaux écarte
l'éventualité d'une intervention en
ukraine face au russe on ne peut pas
imaginer une intervention sous l'égide
de l'onu comme ça a été le cas par
exemple en libye
non alors attendez là intervention qui a
eu en libye il ya eu une résolution de
l'onu qui l'a autorisée au passage la
chine et la russie s'étaient abstenues
vous n'imaginez pas le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu avec la russie et la
chine disposant d'un droit de veto
s'opposer à l'action russe bien sûr
ça peut déborder ailleurs cette guerre
elle peut avoir des conséquences
hors des frontières en ukrainien alors
ça peut avoir des conséquences je
parlais des pays baltes en particulier
puis ça peut avoir des conséquences
surtout dans dans des domaines non
visibles immédiatement je parle en
particulier du cyber et de l'information
et puis regardons nous français ce qui
se passe en afrique l'intervention de
wagner en centrafrique et au mali c'est
directement un affrontement qui
maintenant à plus de masques c'est la
russie même si le président poutine les
yeux dans les yeux dit que la russie n'a
rien à faire avec wagner ça fait partie
de la panoplie de mensonges qu'ils
accumulent depuis quelques semaines
merci beaucoup général trinquent ancien
chef laisse de la mission militaire
française auprès des nations unies nous
avoir éclairé sur france 24